ملاك الموت اكبر مدفع طائر بالعالم
يلقبها اعدائها بجحم السماء
فانيرانها متناثره وقوه تدميرها هائله
انها المقاتله القاتله اي سي 230
الامريكيه في عام
1966 بنت شركه لوك هيد مارتن هيكل هذه
الطائره الثقيله بينما تولد شركه بوينج
تحويلها لطائره مسلحه فكرته هذه الطائره
قديمه وبدات بتحديد في سنوات الحرب
العالميه الثانيه حيث شكل تلك الفتره
الانطلاقه لمشروع طائره بشكل عام في
البدايه كانت هذه الطائرات مخصصه للشحن
ونقل المعدات وانزال جنود المظلات
لكنها تطورت وجهزت باكبر مدفع طائر في
العالم
يصيب هدفه تقريبا من ضربه واحده ثم امتلك
ثلاثه اسلحه اطلاق نار يطلق اثنان منها في
الوقت نفسه اما على الهدف نفسه او على
اهداف وصله كما ان لديها مدفع عن فريده من
نوعه يسمى مبهج الجماهير
يطلق كرات متوهجه يظن البعض انها نوع من
الاستعراض الجوي
لكنها كرات ناريه تزيد درجه حرارتها عند
درجه هيكل الطائره نفسها والهدف من ذلك
المناوره والتخفي من صواريخ قد تستهدفها
ليس هذا فقط فطائرات تمتلك نظام التحذير
ضد الصواريخ الموجهه بالاشعه تحت الحمراء
130 او كما تلقب بملاك الموت او المرعبه
مزوده باربعه محركات توربينيه طاقمها
يتكون من 12 او 13 فردا عسكريا في مقدمتها
يوجد مدفع من نوع يطلق نحو 350 طلقه 10
ثانيه فقط وفي الخلق يوجد سلاح من طراز
وفارس 40 ملمتر يطلق ما يصل الى 100 طلقه
في الدقيقه وهو السلاح الاك دقه واستعمالا
في المعرضه كما انها مزوده باشرس مدفع من
طراز هاوسر عيار 105 ملي متر الذي يعد
الاكبر على متنها كما ان هذا المدفع لا
يوجد له مثيل في اي طائره اخرى في العالم
ويمكنه اطلاق ما يقرب من عشر طلقات في
الدقيقه
ويتم استخدامه ضد المركبات والاهداف
الصلبه واي نوع من الهياكل التي تحتاج الى
الاختراق لكن في الفتره الاخيره تم
تطويرها هذا العملاق ليصبح اكثر وحشيا
تم تطوير الطائره للطراز اي سي 130 يوم
باخراج المدفعين عيار 20 مليمترا
والاستعاده عنهما بمدفع عيار 25 يطلق
1800طلقه في الدقيقه كما تمت زياده قدرتها
في العمل ليلا وفي مختلف الظروف الجويه
السيئه
القوات الجويه الامريكيه هي المستخدم
الرئيسي لهذه الطائره شاركت بها في كل من
حرب فيتنام وحرب الخليج وحرب العراق وحرب
افغانستان والحرب البارده
فهي تحمل مجموعه واسعه من الاسلحه المضاده
للارض التي تتكامل مع اجهزه الاستشعار
المتطوره
وبتسليح بعيار الثقيل يجعلها قادره على
تدمير منطقه باكملها